why don't we go next to uh Tommy from
Wisconsin Tommy from Wisconsin welcome
to the program what's on your mind today
hi David can you hear me all right yes I
can
okay um
I guess I just really had a comment
about Nikki Haley and you know the
possibility and I know it's a ways off
that she might end up as Trump's VP sure
do you think
if he chooses her will she will he will
Trump use her
name Nikki Haley or use her Indian name
what do you think what do you think
Tommy
which name do you think he'll use
um I suspect he'll probably just refer
to her as Nikki Haley so he doesn't end
up slaughtering her like suchintendo
Kerr or so here's the thing this is the
thing so for people who don't know Nikki
Haley's given name was actually nimirata
rondawa okay so um her name now now she
goes by Nikki Haley there's two sides to
this first Trump would love to give her
the Barack Hussein Obama treatment
which would be to refer to her as
nimerata rondawa the problem though is
Trump really struggles with names as we
know you know suchintendo Kerr and Virat
Kohli and when he went to India and
tried to pronounce the names of cricket
players it went really badly so that
would be a reason for Trump to stay away
from that but I think Trump would love
to use her birth name as a way to subtly
criticize her uh with the kind of
xenophobia that he's known for
makes sense to me yeah we'll see what
happens though
right absolutely all right Tommy thank
you beautiful thank you for taking my
call great to hear from you appreciate
it